hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tara's never seen today I am
watching the second Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles movie from 1991 the year I was
born
I watched number one last week and
thought it was really cute very campy
very 80s late a Lee's a Lee's late
eighties early nineties but really fun I
hope it doesn't drop into just like
boring territory
the first was fun campy I hear the last
is just like bad this kind of sounds to
me like it's just gonna drop into like
the boring like it just wasn't like that
good kind of category which is the worst
I'm not here for that you know me
I've already had a lot of pizza today so
I think we should just dive right in you
know I mean let's do it
[Music]
there were definitely some good elements
in this movie but compared to the first
in almost every aspect
this movie was lesser than I a little
nervous to watch the third but let's
talk about the second Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles film let's start off with
that pizza delivery guy who ends up
being in the whole film because Casey
Jones is it that where's Casey Jones
where is he
where'd he go this film owes films a
year if that after the first one they
couldn't like they couldn't get him on
board for that okay cool so then they
hire this annoying pizza guy a friend I
don't know his name's I didn't like him
I didn't learn his name that's my that's
what I do in my life I don't like I
don't like he's first introduced to us
as a pizza delivery guy where he walks
out with his pizza and hits on women who
aren't interested in being hit on he's
like who's gonna ride with me and boom
like cool scooter scoot scoot ladies and
they're like in your dreams buddy
and he goes cool then in my dreams I'll
think of someone thinner
he wrote he better not be a good guy in
this film
hahaha he's like the other human it's
annoying if I don't like him he never
who ruined me
whatever it was 1991 it was very very
different time is very like oh that's
just like a teenager in the 90s like for
sure absolutely it didn't really bother
the damage then so there's a fight to
remind you of who everyone is then you
see April O'Neil who totally looks the
same she's the same person you haven't
changed a bit again one year it's
between the two filming's of these what
they couldn't get the same actors that's
crazy to me that's its craisins that is
craisins to me she was like my favorite
part of the last film she was so
energetic and this one was very not bad
she is what I imagined Megan Fox is
going to be she was very just like not
kind of spazzy and not like very very
excited about the news and the story
she's gonna get just kind of like okay
and then shredder is back okay he went
through like a garbage compactor one two
they show him and and you see his back
and everyone who sees him is like
shredder
your face oh my god and if you see him
and his face is literally like this you
see this
oh so different totally different its
tubular what the cuts yeah
all right so not much there this story
is all about finding the origin of how
the turtles were made and shredder using
that terrifying toxic ooze to turn into
something terrifying Hershey use it to
turn other things into something
terrifying to defeat the journals you
find out that the company that made the
terrifying green ooze is called TGIF
I need no tea GRI so they're trying to
establish this delivery driver guy
that's part of the group now and he
shows up to April O'Neill's house when
she hasn't ordered a pizza and then he
waltzes right in with the pizza and it's
just like talking to her and that I mean
different times different rhymes you
know so 80s and 90s but like if a
delivery person waltzed into my house I
would call the cops and I would give
them a one-star rating on whatever
delivery app service I was using because
we don't have to call restaurants
anymore future then you see that
shredder has taken a wolf and a snapping
turtle and use the green ooze on them to
turn them into scary monsters and
they're hilarious and awkward and weird
and then they start calling shredder
mama and that's it was that was weird
shredder just yells out babies they're
babies ah maybe the best part of the
film then this is a similar thing that I
had with the first one where you know
where this story is gonna go there
aren't any surprises at all except for
when Vanilla Ice and that Billy shows up
that was a wonderful surprise other than
that you know what the story is going so
when they take just such a long time
things it's just kind of like we know
what's going on here we know what's
happening we know what's coming
why are we taking all this time a case
in point the Turtles I don't know their
names the red one the red one is helping
out this annoying pizza delivery guy
join the bad guys so that he could be
like a double agent and so he does he
joins the bad guys comes his double
agent and immediately gets caught
because the red one is there just
hanging out being like do this do this
good don't do that like ask the bad guy
layer what was the point of all of that
you were immediately caught this is
about the point where I realized Casey
was not going to show up again and I got
sad so I said where is my Road on Cory
where is Cory then also where are their
signature weapons like why are they
using them they were using like meat
weapons at the beginning but then they
have their weapons on their turtle
shells they're not using them for some
one reason and that makes the fights way
less cool in this one and like I said in
the last episode I thought the fights
and the first one were pretty sweet
regardless of their giant turtle
exteriors and this one they were just
kind of like okay you're doing some cool
like jump kicks but other than that I
don't know it made it less cool next
thing I wrote in giant letters took up
half the pages oh my god Vanilla Ice go
DJ Ganesha goat amazing he made the
movie so obviously they take down the
snapping turtle and the wolf in it I
will say enjoyable club dance scene with
Vanilla Ice in the background singing go
did you come in to go then of course
shredder himself takes some of the green
slime and turns into this ultimate
shredder which was very cool and in my
mind I was like wow where have you been
why didn't you just do this at the
beginning she looks so much cooler than
regular shredder why was it brought out
for like five seconds
ultimate shredder super shredder yes oh
just kidding he died
sweet and then the last thing I wrote is
oh my god and I don't even know in
reference to what I think it was just
disappointment the mama bit is gonna be
so WTF you may be tempted to see what I
could turn would turn eight into would
mutate into he's sleeping right next to
me should I wake him and ask I should
well I'm good buddy
what would you mutate into if you were
to mutate would you be like a cool that
was a good talk that we had you'll
notice the blatant changes to no weapons
in children rubies yeah okay so that was
a conscious choice super shredder was a
pointless waste yeah you all know
everyone knows all everyone knows the
problems of this film
you will hate the protagonist and
rightfully so kids a piece of these
are the best predictions I've ever
gotten it's you all agree with me for
once in my life
but a lot of combat cold-cuts
mentions in here go Wendy go Wendy go go
Wendy do end go I'm coming back with
Simpson season 2 with my brother I might
do something with Malcolm coming up
really soon
and the third Ninja Turtles movie also
maybe Mighty Ducks I don't know we'll
see you guys will see what I what I have
on the horizon coming up soon
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it
I'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you